[Music]
on this Wednesday night the Bank of
Canada raises its key rate again the
impact of a seventh hike this year so we
haven't seen rates this high in 15 years
the signals of a pause in more increases
as profits plummet for some businesses
stopping a suspected coup Germany's
biggest anti-terror operation and the
far-right extremists arrested
Time Magazine says the choice was clear
we will defend our state Ukraine's
president is Person of the Year
plus bovine intervention he's actually
been chased by some cows at the moment
the cattle that
Moon a fugitive thank you
thank you
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us the
Bank of Canada has done it again raising
its Benchmark interest rate for the
seventh time this year the bank had
warned another hike was coming after a
long stretch of record low rates there's
been a sharp climb over the past nine
months for the trend setting rate seven
hikes at a blistering pace of 400 basis
points puts the bank right now at 4.25
percent the aim is to bring down
inflation which has risen rapidly over
the past two years and there are signs
inflation is beginning to slow many
Canadians are of course watching closely
these decisions directly affect your
cost of living Marnie blunt will get to
that in just a moment but we begin with
Anne gaviola on the rate hike and the
glimmer of optimism that comes with it
Canada's Central Bank hopes the seventh
time in a row is a charm the total
Financial impact of a 50 basis point
increase year to date for the average
homeowner is
1415 more per month nearly 17 000 per
year that's an increase of 55 percent in
mortgage payments people with variable
rate debt will feel the impact almost
immediately and many may not be prepared
we haven't seen rates this high in 15
years so they are they are considerably
higher than than what what most of us
have become used to but there's a sign
that Bank may be nearing the end of this
tightening cycle previous messaging from
the Central Bank indicated rates needed
to rise further but now it says it will
consider future hikes leaving the door
open to a pause or smaller increases in
2023 at this point any relief will help
with higher borrowing costs and higher
prices for nearly everything it's a lot
all at once the concerns that people
have about their own financial situation
are more acute now than they were during
the height of the pandemic ipsos polling
exclusively for global news shows 71
percent of respondents fear interest
rates will rise faster than they can
adjust 61 percent are concerned about
affording gas 53 percent scared they
won't have enough to feed their families
more than half afraid they won't have
enough money for holiday gifts and a
whopping 86 percent worried about a
recession economists are divided on
whether or not 2023 will bring one but
for many it's not a matter of if but
when can meetings are already changing
their behavior as a result they're
raining in their holiday spending
they're spending Less on luxuries
parents women and young Canadians are
most likely to be worried about what's
to come that's no surprise as experts
say they are already bearing the brunt
of the rising cost of living but a
spending slowdown is just what the Bank
of Canada ordered to alleviate the
soaring cost of living that's still a
long way from the central bank's Target
of two percent
[Music]
inside Silver Fox Barber Shop hair isn't
the only thing being cut the number of
customers coming through the door nearly
chopped in half staff say cost of
livings to blame we see a two to three
week cycle for haircuts normally now
we're seeing a four to six week cycle
although montemaro says that's also
driven their product prices 25 to 30
percent higher to make up revenues even
here staff can only trim so much
unfortunately I think next year we'll
have no other choice but to raise our
prices our cost of our supplies are
going up they're feeling it in Center
town at happy goat coffee too for the
last I want to say 25 30 days we've seen
an incline a decline in our revenues
across the board really higher costs and
less demand will likely come back to
bite customers as costs go up our prices
to the consumer go up right obviously at
the end of the day the consumer pays for
it unfortunately
Canadians are already paying in a big
way Financial experts say more of us may
soon feel the pinch this rate hike is
still going to put people in that
position where they're thinking about
you know where they're spending their
money in particular for first-time home
buyers some already forced to put their
house hunting on hold for the
foreseeable future I could afford the
down payment
but now in terms of the mortgage with
this interest rate hike you know I would
be expecting to pay something
significantly higher and whether it's on
mortgages rent gas or groceries all of
us are looking for ways to save the
grocery store has become
um I think an active you know heartburn
you know every time you see the prices
at you know every week they go up and so
I think that's really pinching some
Canadians and of course Financial
stressors often only intensify heading
into the holidays and credit counseling
Canada says that will likely lead to
many Canadians seeking financial help
come January Donna all right Marty blunt
in Ottawa thank you in Montreal it is
the first full day of the un's
biodiversity conference International
delegates are trying to agree on how to
preserve the Earth's ecosystems and it's
happening on a notable anniversary 50
years ago this portrait of the earth
known as the Blue Marble was captured by
astronauts during NASA's final Apollo
Mission became a potent symbol for
environmentalists capturing a vulnerable
Planet Without Borders that needs to be
protected Mike Armstrong looks at
Canada's Promises at the conference and
how indigenous peoples are at the
Forefront
[Music]
on the first full day of cop15 the
federal government's Focus was
indigenous the Prime Minister announced
funding of up to 800 million dollars
aimed at conservation initiatives that
are specifically indigenous-led Majors
support the Prime Minister says to
protect biodiversity and promote
reconciliation it takes resources to
create a conservation economy where
caring for the land is a career
opportunity
and where people can be stewards of
their own homes the funding will Target
four conservation projects one in
British Columbia and three in the north
together it would mean the protection of
about a million square kilometers wow I
don't even know where to start
I was all ready to show my every child
matters t-shirt and talk about the
challenges our communities still face on
a daily basis
but it's important to keep picture of
the fact that we're taking control of
our own destiny again thanks to today's
wonderful announcement thank you to both
of you for this tremendous bold step
now Canada isn't just one of cop 15's
co-hosts along with China it's also
important globally in terms of nature
this country has 24 percent of the
world's fresh water 24 of all Wetlands
25 percent of temperate rainforests and
33 percent of the world's boreal forests
now on this first day of the convention
there was work but there were also the
first protests a group marched around
the heavily protected Convention Center
this protester says there have been
enough conventions the world needs real
change
more than 20 000 students in Montreal
are out on strike this week around cop
15. the weather may have been a factor
but this March was smaller than expected
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal
there is disturbing news out of Germany
about a far-right group that was
plotting to overthrow the government at
least 25 people have been arrested in
what's being described as the country's
largest anti-terror operation early this
morning 150 police raids were carried
out and among those arrested were
members of Germany's police and Special
Forces Germany's government says
far-right extremism is now the biggest
threat to its democracy Crystal
gemancing Reports on the details of the
plot and the people behind it
handcuffed and taken into custody
officials say this meant Heinrich the
13th a German Aristocrat was one of the
ringleaders plotting a violent
government takeover military
militant reisberger United by the hatred
for democracy for our state and for
people who support our community The
Fringe group has been operating in
Germany for decades railing against
modern democracy during the pandemic
however its extreme ideologies seem to
have tapped into a new audience
connecting with Believers of deep State
conspiracies according to the federal
prosecutor Peter Frank the group
appeared to have established a shadow
government as a part of preparations
according to our information individual
members of the terrorist group
considered entering Parliament by force
the alleged plot resembles the
Insurgency in the United States when the
capital was stormed on January 6 last
year Q Anon supporters were involved
then and some of those arrested
Wednesday are set to follow the group as
well
German media report that among the 25
taken into custody is birgit mic
winkelmann a Berlin district court judge
and former right-wing politician a
64-year-old ex-german army officer was
also taken into custody in Italy where
police say They seized materials related
to the organization while far-right
groups have existed particularly in
Europe for ages they're gaining
prominence around the globe historian
Joshua Arthurs they're emboldened by the
emergence of uh of political figures on
the right in mainstream politics
which gives them a platform or a cause
to identify with although authorities
say the group had little chance at
succeeding the potential to upend
society and disrupt the normal working
order is something German officials say
they won't risk
Crystal gemancing Global News London
25 people arrested today have ties to
the reichsberger who reject the modern
German State and believe it
illegitimately replaced the Deutsche
Reich of the Nazi era Germany's domestic
intelligence service estimates the group
has more than 21 Thousand members and
about 5 percent of them more than 1100
People are classified as far-right
extremists 10 percent are considered
violent in the past few years German
authorities have revoked weapons permits
for hundreds of the movements followers
new allegations of Chinese interference
coming up the rcmb contract with a
company that has ties to the Chinese
government plus the new honor for the
late Queen
the federal government has announced
what it says are major changes to the
rules governing foreign investment in
Canada to address National Security
concerns the government says it wants to
continue encouraging foreign investment
but says it needs enhanced tools to
better protect vital sectors of the
economy such as critical minerals and
Quantum Computing the changes are in
legislation tabled in the House of
Commons today
the reality is geopolitics of the world
today has vastly changed in the last few
years that's why we must be prepared to
face the challenges that could endanger
our Economic Security
and I would say National Security
and there are more reports of Chinese
interference in Canada this time and
RCMP equipment contract awarded to a
company with ties to the Chinese
government a CBC Radio Canada
Investigation found the contract
involves maintaining the rcmp's radio
communications equipment the Prime
Minister said today he finds that
disconcerting absolutely we're going to
be following up on this uh finding out
first of all what needs to be done to
ensure
that our Communications technology is
secure
but also make sure we're figuring out
how this could continue to happen
according to radio Canada's reporting
public services and procureum in Canada
gave a three-year contract worth more
than 500 thousand dollars to Sinclair
Technologies in October 2021 through an
investment fund the Chinese government
owns 10 percent of a Sinclair parent
company hyterra Communications hyterra
is banned in the U.S because of National
Security concerns and is named in an
indictment for allegedly stealing Trade
Secrets
China is moving away from its zero covid
policy announcing the most significant
loosening of restrictions since the
virus was first detected in late 2019.
people seem to support the decision to
drop testing for domestic travel and the
move to allow home quarantine for mild
cases for weeks protesters had demanded
the constraints on daily life be lifted
it was the largest showing of dissent
and discontent for the government of Xi
Jinping since he took office however the
government did not link the new coven
policies to that protest movement
in Jamaica the Prime Minister has
declared a widespread state of emergency
in an attempt to fight a surge in gang
violence the measures allow authorities
to arrest people and to search buildings
without a warrant Jamaica has one of the
highest murder rates per capita in the
world the popular tourist destination of
Montego Bay is covered by the state of
emergency
Advocates feeling cut out of
consultation ahead of global news
investigation into Ontario's abortion
care crisis
thank you
We are continuing our series on how
abortion clinics in Ontario are funded
in part one we told you some clinics are
so worried about funding they solicit
donations from the public Ontario says
it's committed to overhauling the
financing structure but experts say
there is a glaring problem the
government has not asked abortion
providers for their input tonight
Jasmine Pizano explains how this could
impact the future of care I wanted to
talk to you about this actually Omar
runs an abortion clinic in Ontario
Global News agreed not to reveal his
last name or where he works
it says Ontario is committed to
revisiting the current framework for
funding insured surgical abortion
services
have you heard about this not at all
part of Ontario's promise is to consider
how its potential changes could affect
abortion providers Global News
interviewed several staff members from
abortion clinics in the province but
none say they've been contacted by the
government
I try to be optimistic maybe they're
busy until you brought to my attention I
have not heard about this Carolyn Egan
has been advocating for abortion rights
in Ontario for decades she says that
she's been left out too those of us who
are in the field are always very
cautious about decisions being made at a
level higher than ourselves in many
senses without input from from people on
the ground who are providing the service
there's a reason Ontario had to come up
with this plan and the details are in
the latest Canada Health act annual
report around 2018 The Province found
out one abortion clinic was charging
patients illegal facility fees this to
pay for an aspirator equipment used to
remove pregnancy tissue patients gave
nearly fourteen thousand dollars out of
their own Pockets over a year's time
abortions are covered by Ontario and
it's illegal for health care providers
to charge fees for insured Services it
seems like it was something that was a
mistake that was then corrected that
clinic received no extra money from the
province it's also stopped at surgical
abortions but in reaction to this case
Ontario made a commitment to health
Canada last December it would consider
funding all surgical abortion service
providers and Facilities certainly those
services that are providing abortion
should be funded equally and that's not
the case right now the province fully
funds only half of its independent
surgical abortion clinics if we're not
getting that kind of funding we are
definitely threatening access and the
existence of the clinics in an email
Global News asked Ontario why it has not
reached out to clinics directly a health
Ministry spokesperson responded but did
not provide any details I'm just hoping
that they do in Truth Listen to those
who are in the field to those who are
seeking abortions and those advocacy
groups that have been working for so
long to provide adequate access workers
on the front lines are desperate to be
heard
please reach out we would love to come
up with a better way to implement like
funding and provide services for women
because at the end of the day that's
honestly the only thing we ever really
cared about determined to do whatever
they can to continue giving this
life-changing care Jasmine pizzano
Global News Toronto
[Music]
times person of the year next why he's
an inspiration for the world
he's actually been chased by some cows
at the moment
well this is one way to catch a
suspected criminal this is night vision
footage from a police helicopter in the
UK I'd heard of curious cows tailed the
suspect and moved him out of the field
and into the arms of waiting officers
the puns are coming thick and fast about
the high stakes Chase police said they
were grateful to the cows but did have
to remind them not to take the law into
their own hooves
well her image is on so many coins it's
impossible to count now there is another
tribute to the late Queen Elizabeth II
the Royal Canadian Mint unveiled this
toony with a black nickel outer ring
representing a morning band nearly 5
million of these will be produced and
they will enter circulation later this
month
the Ukrainian president hasn't graced
any coins yet but he was given a special
honor today the Vladimir zielinski and
the spirit of Ukraine are Time
magazine's person of the year when
Russia invaded Ukraine its goal was to
kill or capture zielinski and decapitate
his government instead zielinski a
former actor has defied Vladimir Putin
and as Eric Sorensen reports he is
recognized for his Courage by Ukraine
and the world
when the Russian attack began chaos and
killing descended on Ukraine many
expected the country to fall and its
leader to flee and yet there he was
listen I am here he said we will defend
our state the world hardly knew Vladimir
zelenski
a former comedian known for a TV role as
The Accidental president of Ukraine as
the real leader he resisted efforts by
then U.S president Trump to dig up dirt
to hurt Joe Biden but few most notably
Vladimir Putin expected he could
withstand the Russian Onslaught
yet zelenski has been Resolute compared
with Winston Churchill in World War II
he has buoyed the spirits of the
Ukrainian people
and risked his life to be with soldiers
near the front lines glory to Ukraine he
tells them
there is a heavy toll but we've seen the
Ukrainian army fight back with Valor
with bravery and president zielinski as
the head of that government as the head
of that Army is is the brave face uh and
and Communicator to the world about
what's happening in Ukraine zielinski
has kept the world's attention on
Ukraine kept the West committed in its
support the choice for a person of the
year was the most clear-cut in memory
said Time Magazine recognizing not only
zelenski
but the spirit of Ukraine the strength
of its people after almost 10 months of
war the country is a shell of its former
existence this man looks at the car he
used to drive a woman is grateful just
to receive water yet their Spirit has
not faltered
Ukraine will win we will get through it
she says we will prevail
the soldiers and the people are one in
their determination to fight on for a
country that has long resisted Russian
subjugation the more the Russians attack
the Ukrainian civilian population the
less afraid they are zielinski embodies
that unity and the spirit of a nation
that will not give in to tyranny the
role of a lifetime for a comedian turned
president Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna frieden tonight's
your Canada is the CP holiday train
traveling through Indian Head
Saskatchewan we'd love to see your
festive Canada photos please email them
to viewers at globalnational.com and
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]